nice to see you again
good to see you too
uh so after i watched this movie the
first thing i thought was this is like
the john wick movie for princess films
like this is you're so badass in this
thank you so much i have to agree with
you this movie is pretty badass yeah now
it's interesting to learn that you
weren't always supposed to do all of the
stunts but that's how it turned out so
what changed
basically
um when i started training for the movie
i think people realized how passionate i
was about really getting as good as i
could um and how i really i told
everyone i was like i really want to do
everything that i can possibly do and so
when i started training in the beginning
we didn't have choreography or anything
for these fights it was just teaching me
the basics and building me up from there
and so as i kept training when the
fights were built they were starting to
be built around what my strengths were
in fighting and what i got really good
at um and so i'm so grateful to the
stunt team because they really took
every little thing into account when
creating the fights uh to to be
beneficial for me and and to make me
look good and to to be great for me and
to challenge me but to also
accentuate what i already became good at
and i have to say my two stunt doubles
um they
were just unbelievably crucial to me
being able to do everything that i did
um you know they're there to pretend to
be me when i need them but i have to say
they were
my biggest cheerleaders in
in
advocators for me doing everything
myself they lifted me up so much
are you hooked now are we gonna see you
as the next big action star because i'd
like to see that
honestly you know me i love i love doing
many many different things so i don't
think i could sit down and commit to one
kind of genre yeah but i really hope
this isn't the last time i do action
because i absolutely loved it well you
were so good and you know what's
interesting when i think of some of my
favorite action heroines that i've seen
in some of my favorite movies i think
sigourney weaver uma thurman charlize
theron is there anyone that stands out
for you that you've admired over the
years
i have to say all those names you just
said are absolutely incredible and also
i really looked up to veronica she was
really
she just has such a way about her she's
so confident in her skill and um she's
so calm with the way she fights i'm
definitely more of like uh is veronica
so clean with her fighting and then
there's me and i'm always grunting like
i'm playing tennis like
um
but i just it was amazing to work with
someone who had so much experience um
and all those women that you just named
i mean charlize's um atomic blonde
was just such a big uh inspiration for
me as far as how i wanted these fights
to be built and i wanted the princess to
become exhausted i didn't want it to
seem like she was just powering through
these fights with no problem um that
movie really inspired me because
charlize is so amazing and badass in it
but she gets really beat up and really
knocked around and i wanted the same
thing for the princess yeah well you
nailed it because that's such a really
good inspiration i can totally see the
similarities um can we just talk about
your life right now you're starring in
the princess we're going to see you on
bullet train uh with brad pitt and then
it was just announced you're in a comedy
with nicole kidman and zac efron how do
you describe life right now
it's pretty fast-paced huh it's pretty
crazy life is moving real quickly and
it's it's it's i'm trying to really take
it all in because this is such an
amazing moment for me not just in my
career but in my personal life um i mean
there's so many wonderful things
happening right now in my life and so
it's just i don't want it to just all
go by like a bullet train haha um i want
to really take it in and just appreciate
every moment so i'm trying to take those
moments in because i mean it's going to
go by so fast yeah well congratulations
on your engagement too
thank you so much